welcome back it is 8 40 and man we've
made it to friday west michigan that
means there's some great comedy shows to
catch our guest today one of the
comedians here in town performing this
weekend we got akash singh with us
what's up camera two how are you doing i
know camera two doing pretty well hey
you're gonna have fun all right so we
have a fun trivia game we like to play
with everybody okay all right i assume
the white comedians are much better at
trivia
no i don't necessarily think i don't
know we'll see we'll see how you do all
right what's a white cap
again you're asking the wrong guy i the
white comedian would know this what is a
white cat a white cap is you know when
the snow waves no no when the waves are
in the lake they they have white caps
when it gets a little rough out there
that's what a white cap is you
boating on the top of those waves that's
see how know
those little white caps yeah
mike is telling me he has something to
do with baseball what is it well it is
it also it's a white it's a team it's a
that wins two that wins oh is it the
minor league team ding yeah okay feeder
team to the tigers so that west michigan
white caps they play in grand rapids so
yes that's also a winning answer yeah
grand rapids feeder city into chicago
well detroit right no i was gonna say
detroit but who wants to be fed to
detroit all right welcome
detroit god is already doing that am i
right camera one
anyway
what world famous breakfast food sauce
created no
okay
sorry kellogg's
oh no that i might not have known but i
think i would have i'm gonna let you
finish the next question okay let's go
do you know what a clomping dancing is
i told you these are for white people
a clump and dance keith you ever heard
of a clump and dancing
no help from the peanut gallery out
there now let me tell you i knew keith
wasn't going to help me all right okay
you were in holland though yes okay so
clomp and dancing is kind of the dutch
dancing with the wooden shoes believe it
or not i don't have a big dutch
following
really yeah
you were in holland
who thought looking at me i didn't know
holland keith booked me in holland
he didn't you didn't know my demographic
keith there's no indians in holland
what are you doing bro man
i don't know
i'm going to give you these because i
know you're going to wear them with
pride yes of course what are these uh
these are some amazing fox 17 sunglasses
i'll take off i'll take them out of the
wrapper for you nothing really more than
fox news sunglasses fox 17 not fox news
but thank you what's up guys
hey grand rapids i'll see y'all twice
tomorrow first show sold out second show
getting there muskegon
we can use some sales i'm gonna be
honest with you you guys want to come
out there there you go friday back alley
comedy club that sounds fun all right so
i think you head to our website you can
pick up some tickets yeah head out to
muskegon tonight absolutely all right
akash well thank you for your time thank
you
have fun in west michigan i have a
feeling i won't be seeing michelle of
these shows you know what i mean if i'm
if i'm am i wrong camera one hey give me
a lot of credit not a lot of chemistry
going on here comedically
i just love comedians so i should do i
love having them on the show it's my
favorite favorite thing i can tell it is
8 45 now